the other day I briefly talked about a
racially segregated holiday party that
was thrown by the mayor of Boston
Michelle woo and in case you missed it
uh the basic idea here is that the
mayor's office only wanted to invite the
non-white members of the Boston city
council to the event they wanted to
exclude all the white people and to that
end the mayor staff sent out a bunch of
emails addressed to quote electeds of
color which is yet another example of
the fact that leftists are simply
incapable of speaking actual English
they're on their way to creating their
own language at this point but there was
a problem with the Party by mistake the
mayor's office sent out invitations to
all of Boston City's council members
including the white Devils wasn't just
elected of color who got an invite and
uh seven white people got one too and in
an Administration that cared about the
Constitution or basic morality this
would be a highly embarrassing episode
the mayor would apologize for
discriminating on the basis of race and
then she would
resign but that's not what happened in
this case instead Michelle woo uh
yesterday after we talked about this she
did apologize but not for the
Discrimination instead she apologized
only for accidentally sending the
invitation to white people she says that
that was the only error she made was in
just sending the invitation to everybody
the the the the crackers weren't
supposed to get one that's basically her
her apology
watch tonight Boston's mayor Michelle
woo admits that a mistake was made in an
invitation to a holiday party members of
the Boston city council received an
email invitation to what's called a
gathering of electeds of color not all
members of the council fit that
description I think we've we've had
individual conversations with everyone
so people understand that it was truly
just a an honest mistake that went out
in in typing the email field and um I
look forward to celebrating with
everyone at the holiday parties that we
will have besides this one as well so um
it is my intention that we can again um
be a city that lives our values and
creates space for all kinds of
communities to come together the mayor
apologizing for any confusion at the
original email
created apologizing for the confusion
but not for the fact that she is
racially segregating her holid parties
uh the mayor also clarified that this
electeds of color party has been going
on for several years and it's only now
been discovered because of the mistake
that her staff made so uh rest easy the
racial discrimination is nothing new
she's been doing this forever that's the
position of the mayor's office as of
tonight now or or last night rather
whatever you make of that uh there are a
few legal experts who have suggested
that it might as you would expect
violate Massachusetts law which does not
allow government officials to use City
resources to enforce racial segregation
the Massachusetts Public accommodations
act a bars officials from quote making
any distinction discrimination or
restriction in admission to or treatment
in a place of public accommodation based
on race this event was held at the uh
Parkman house which is owned by the city
although it's not open to the public so
maybe that's the out here I don't know
seem that seems pretty spous at best
maybe the mayor can say that it's legal
to discriminate on the basis of race as
long as it's in a city building that is
not a public
accommodation although it's a city
building it's not open to the public so
it's not a public accommodation uh maybe
that's the legal
argument I don't think it's a very
convincing one
that still doesn't address the question
of why Michelle wo was so intent on
keeping white people away from this
event to begin with and it's especially
strange given that Michelle wo has a
white husband so you might be tempted to
think that maybe she just wanted to
attend a holiday party without her
husband around and that's why she came
up with this whole idea maybe that's
what's going on here I don't know she
also has two half-white children so uh
are they allowed to come to the party
maybe they can be at the party for half
the time I don't know is that how it
works but this is not a completely
satisfying explanation mainly because it
does seem that the mayor has a
deep-seated disdain for white people in
general for one thing just a year ago
woo cracked a joke about how many white
problems she's had to deal with in the
city uh you might remember this
watch it's over a 100 days we have
connected unhoused residents at Mass
encast to housing treatment and services
we've launched three free bus lines
we've taken some big bold actions but I
won't lie this past winter was pretty
intense trial by snow trial by fire
fighters
Union I'm getting used to dealing with
problems that are expensive disruptive
and white I'm talking about snowflakes
snowflakes I mean snowstorm
snowflakes oh yeah and I forgot that was
at the St Patrick's Day breakfast so
this is a you know supposed to be a
breakfast celebrating Irish Americans
and that's when she makes the anti-white
joke you know it's like but I mean I'm
sure that would definitely happen in the
reverse you know you can imagine a
politician going to a Kwanza breakfast
and then complaining about all the black
problem she has to deal with that would
totally
happen and this is the point where you
have to wonder how someone like Michelle
woo became the mayor of a city like
Boston given that she clearly hates most
of the city's residents based on their
skin color in fact even though the white
population in Boston is declining like
it is in every major city it's still one
of the whitest major cities in the
country and yet it has arguably the most
anti-white mayor in the country which is
pretty high bar to get over how does
that happen well not a lot of people are
asking that question right now even in
Boston as I mentioned yesterday even
white members of the city council the
very people that woo excluded from the
holiday party because of their skin
color are mostly shrugging this whole
episode off they're suggesting it's an
isolated incident as if that somehow
would make racial segregation acceptable
and even though we know it's not
isolated she said herself that she's
been uh doing it a lot we also know it's
not an isolated incident for a lot of
other reasons you know you don't hear a
lot about it but explicit anti-white
discrimination is well no longer unusual
in this country at all and I'm I'm not
talking about just racial bias or
affirmative action admissions we've
talked plenty of that about that racial
preferences and hiring and promotions um
everyone knows that that's been going on
I'm talking about policies in government
and universities and school systems that
overtly ban white people from
participating this is a real thing that
is happening all the time and it's not
just happening at the mayor's holiday
party in Boston racial segregation has
made a comeback in this country in a big
way you just don't hear very much about
it and the people who are advocating for
it won't call it
that like they would never call it a
racially segregated holiday party but
that of course is exactly what it is
it's the season of giving but you've
already given enough to your internet
service provider if you haven't been
using expressvpn when you go online and
I'm not just talking about the enormous
internet bill that you pay every month
every time you go online without
expressvpn your internet service
provider can see and log every single
website you visit and yes that includes
includes all the sites you visit in
incognito mode in addition to
overcharging you your ISP is legally
allowed to sell all your browsing
activity to third party advertisers for
massive profits well I'm done giving to
my internet service provider I always go
online with expressvpn the app encrypts
and reroutes 100% of my network data
through their secure servers so my
provider can't see anything the app
could be easier to use simply fire up
expressvpn on any of your devices phone
laptop whatever it is tap one button to
connect and that's it you're in unlike
your internet service provider Express
vvpn is committed to your privacy their
privacy policy has even been audited by
Third parties so you can rest assured
that your data is not being logged by
anyone you've given enough to your
internet service provider this year so
take back your internet privacy today
with the VPN rated number one by tech
radar and Mashable visit expressvpn.com
Walsh and get three extra months of
expressvpn for free that's exp rsvpn
docomo expressvpn.com Walsh to learn
more are you are you one of the millions
of American men and women of any age
dealing with premature hair thinning or
hair loss maybe you're scared about
inheriting that thinning look because it
runs in the family there's a real
solution that delivers on its promise
without the harsh side effects unwanted
chemicals or a need for a prescription
provia uses a safe natural ingredient
called prael to effectively Target the
three main causes of premature hair
thinning and loss provia delivers
nourishing nurt nutrients to support
healthy scalp circulation and stronger
hair follicles uh provia guarantees more
more hair on your head than in the
shower or on your comb effective for men
and women of any age provia is safe on
colored treated and styled hair right
now new customer save over 50% plus free
shipping on provo's introductory package
at provia.com Walsh every package
includes a full 60-day supply of provia
serum for daily use plus the provia
super concentrate for faster more
noticeable results every order includes
your choice of a free gift right now
provia works guaranteed or 100% of your
money back don't wait order now and save
an extra 10% off just in time for the
holidays at provia.com that's provia.com
right now for example a school district
in Illinois is segregating its English
and math classes by race at evanstown
Township High School black and Latino
students go into one classroom when it's
time to learn English and calculus and
algebra and then whites and Asians go
into a different
classroom this is um the kind of program
that legal experts say is clearly
unconstitutional if anyone sued it would
be struck down
immediately but people are not suing
people are just letting it go on so the
program continues they even have a name
for this whole system of racial
discrimination the school system the
school board calls it Axel and that
means advancing Excellence lifting
everyone lifting Everyone by dividing
them as shocking as it sounds it's
nothing new for Chicago a couple years
ago Chicago's mayor at the time Lori
lighfoot announced that for one day she
would not talk to White reporters she
just straight up said that she would not
deal with any white reporters again
there was mostly a collective shrug from
reporters in the city when this happened
watch today Chicago mayor lightfoot's
2-year anniversary in office to mark
that occasion Lightfoot announced she
would only Grant one-on-one interviews
to black and brown journalist WGN
political reporter Taman Bradley sat
down with her to learn more about that
decision your office says you invited
black and brown journalists to to this
round of interview uh why I'm happy to
vouch for Craig wall for Heather Chiron
and others well look I I I think in this
one day when we are looking at uh the
2-year anniversary of my inauguration as
a woman of a color um as a a lesbian
it's important to me that diversity is
put front and center mayor Lori
Lightfoot defending her most unusual
decision to only invite black and brown
journalists to her office for one-on-one
interviews the move infuriated the
mostly White City Hall press
Corps yes let's make it more diverse by
making it less diverse of course that
makes a lot of sense and Lori lefoot
never apologize for that why should she
she understands that in Chicago the
third biggest city in United States open
anti-white race hate isn't just
tolerated it's popular it's fine I mean
they claimed there that the Press score
was infuriated no they weren't really
they weren't really um they certainly
did not express any any real Fury and of
course there are many more examples in
the wake of George Floyd's overdose rice
University students uh demanded the
construction of a literal black house on
campus along with segregated housing and
last year the New York Post reported
that an off-campus housing Co-op at UC
Berkeley had banned white people from
the common areas this is a five-story
building called the person of color
theme house and here's an excerpt from
the house rules quote many POC moved
here to be able to avoid white violence
and presence so respect their decision
of avoidance if you bring white guests
white guests are not allowed in common
spaces in fact some white guests weren't
allowed at all in the entire building as
one student reported quote I was not
allowed to let my dad enter the house
because he's white now if you're
wondering where Berkeley's
Administration stood on all this the
answer is that they supported of course
anti-white hatred is endemic at the
University three years ago in the summer
of George Floyd a third-year student
named Seth Smith was shot in the back of
the head execution style while he was
out for a walk and Smith's killer was a
black career Criminal Who mocked Smith
for being white when he was
arrested after he just executed him how
did Berkeley administrators respond to
that incident well the chancellor
released this statement quote many of
you may have had a close relationship
with Seth and are feeling a sense of
loss and disbelief others like many of
us are experiencing stress grief and
anxiety related to the coronavirus
pandemic and the recent murders of
George Floyd Ryan Milton and other black
Americans in other words sorry about the
white kid who just got murdered but
isn't the death of George Floyd a felon
with no connection whatsoever to Berk
also really
upsetting that's what they said you know
imagine being one of Seth Smith's
friends or family members and seeing
that
email you'd understand the message
immediately which is that you know he
doesn't really matter because he's too
white this is a message that Berkeley
has communicated a lot recently in in
various ways for example the university
recently held a Black's only graduation
ceremony they've been doing this every
year for a while now but uh earlier this
year one clip from this graduation
ceremony went viral
[Applause]
watch uh AR Miss Anderson said the last
shall be first and the first shall be
last receiving a Bachelor of Arts in
disciplinary studies field political
economy legal studies and
African-American studies he said
dispersement and allocation reparations
for
African-Americans so that is a state
funded segregation there are many more
examples of it outside the Bay Area as
of 2019 more than 75 universities in
this country offer black only graduation
ceremonies the actual number by now is
probably much higher than that Harvard
still hosts Affinity celebrations for
graduates which are subdivided by skin
color you know white people of course
are the only racial group that don't get
one but everyone else gets a specific
one depending on what you look like what
your skin color is what's important to
keep in mind is that none of these
incidents are National scandals they
obviously should be but they haven't
been and in many cases the people being
discriminated against don't seem to mind
that much I mean those impacted by these
policies could file lawsuits and even in
our court system they could easily win
many of these lawsuits because a lot of
this stuff just is not remote Ely legal
you can't do this kind of thing
especially if you're a government
institution public institution but but
nobody challenges it nobody
sues nobody even objects most of the
time and because of that ambivalence
racial Equity is rapidly becoming what
it was always destined to become which
is the return of racial
segregation hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there